we already knew that titanfall 2 had a
single player campaign but now we've
learned a bunch more about how it
operates I'm Tony and this is your
Titanic gamespot news update first off
you can change your Titans load out on
the fly if you want flame weapons you
can select scorcher if you want energy
weapons you can select die on you can
also talk to your titan BTW 72-74 using
rudimentary dialogue choices and it's
not just your own robot powell you'll
encounter either titanfall 2 will have
boss battles against unique titans as
for the world itself the path to your
objective takes cues from open-world
games letting you blaze your own Trail
developer respawn says these objectives
have a 211 split in other words the
campaign is two parts pilot combat one
part Titan combat and one part puzzles
that all sounds very promising titanfall
2 comes to ps4 xbox one and pc on
october twenty eighth and it definitely
sounds like there will be tons of stuff
to do when it drops stick with gamespot
for plenty more coverage between then
and now and for all the biggest
titanfall 2 news you're already in the
right place